ain't that amazing you know we still
can't prevent to hangover we have all
this medical research I've tried the
water I've tried the pills nothing works
we can prevent
children
right we can't run a hangover you know
at least some people want kids I've
never woken up like woo I am really hung
over but you know what I think I want to
keep
it yeah I got to cut back on the sauce
man I uh I blacked out last week that's
embarrassing too old for that I told my
roommate he's like oh you blacked out oh
that means you forgot to brush your
teeth last
night I was like wow that is the least
of my
worries I'm more concerned with the
lipstick I'm wearing why sent my mom a
dickpic